Good morning, everyone. It's Mark Wiens and it is a very early morning here in Bangkok. We got a flight at 2 a.m.
and we caught a taxi to Suvarnabhumi Airport in Bangkok. And Ying and I are on our way to the island of
Langkawi, which is in northern Malaysia, and it's actually right near the border of Thailand in the south
but we've got a fly from Bangkok to Kuala lumpur first. It's flight number one and then with from Kuala Lumpur
we got to fly to
island of Langkawi, so we are about to catch our first flight now
to KL.
It is about 4:30 a.m. and I think this is the quietest I have ever seen this airport. A couple weeks ago
I was contacted by Naturally Langkawi, which is under the tourism of Malaysia branch and
they invited us for a trip to Langkawi
for a full week to do a bunch of things and eat a lot of delicious food.
So, Ying and I are on our way now to Langkawi, and I think this should be a really, really fun trip
But also, I want to say a big thank you for watching it was yesterday's
I think yesterday's vlog depending on when I upload this this vlog, but thank you all for the positive feedback.
I really appreciate it and since you guys enjoyed that I decided I am going to try to make a daily vlog
for this trip to Langkawi.
So keep coming back. I'm going to be uploading a daily vlog
We have so many cool activities that are on our schedule as well as a lot of delicious food
Here's a quick photo of langkawi the island that we're going to. So this is
actually Thailand comes all the way down south and then this is Malaysia. And then you can see
right there is the island we are going to call Langkawi.
I
fell asleep before we even took off and I was sleeping
but I just woke up for breakfast now and I order the nasi lemak,
which is traditional Malaysian food.
The peanuts - okay, let me go and get piece of the egg in the prawn.
It's scorching hot.
Okay, so we just landed in Kuala Lumpur and the flight was just under two hours, and I think we have a
two-hour layover. Bye-bye. Thank you.
But yeah, that was a good flight. Umm, I
got a good nap in there
And then ate that. Just woke up to eat that nasi lemak. Got about two hours before flight to Langkawi
So going to do some email.
We're on flight number two now. On our way to Langkawi and a flight should just be about 45 minutes from Kuala Lumpur.
We have landed at Langkawi International Airport.  It is a safety requirement that you remain seated until the aircraft comes to a complete stop. Seat belt sign has been switched off.
We're going to go get our bag and there should be someone here to pick us up
Thank you. Okay.
There's our name right there. Oh, thank you.
HelloQ
Hello!
Thank you very much.
What is the name of the restaurant we're going to now?
The Seashells... the Seashells Restaurant.
And we are now in the car on our way to a restaurant called The Seashells, which is in an area called
Laman Padi, which is the rice field, rice field area and
so we are gonna go for lunch, and I am very ready to eat lunch.
We are eating a dish called nasi campur,
which is rice with a bunch of different curries and they had all the curries in
kind of the front of the restaurant, and so we chose
Oh
I chose a couple of different fish, chickens and
beef. The food looks awesome and our guide Wankesh is gonna
just quickly explain a couple of the dishes. Daging kurma.
Daging kurma. "Daging" is "beef". Okay. "Kurma" is maybe
Arabic-style.  Oh,
like who like "kurma".
Okay, okay. This is - in Malay, we call it "ayam masak merah".
"Ayam" is "chicken". Okay, "Masak" is the "cooked".
Okay. "Merah" is "red". Okay, and then this one is Ikan bakar. Ikan bakar. What type of - which is grilled?
It's grilled fish. Grilled fish.
It's like butterfly cut. Yes, butterfly cut. And then grilled with some sambal. Sambal, yeah.
And then this is like a - is it shrimp paste? Shrimp paste. Oh!
In Malay, we call it "air asam". Actually, I think I should just put a bunch of things on my plate
before I start eating. Here goes that the chicken - the red chicken curry.
Oh, that is looking flavourful.
Next chicken curry on this side of the plate
Omelette goes right on top there.
And then revolve the plate. And then this is the beef dish in coconut milk.
and then fried fish.
Then, finally, this one is the ikan bakar, the grilled fish, which is one of my favorite things to eat in Malaysia.
And I'm gonna. Actually, I don't think I'll even add this to my plate.
I think I will just break off a piece and eat. Actually, this is going to have to be my first bite
I'm gonna reach in for some of this shrimp paste - chilli sauce - put that onto the fish.
Yeah, I gotta - I gotta reach in for a bite immediately of this ikan bakar.
Mmm, that fish is extremely juicy and it has a wonderful like - kind of like
roasted - very like -
chili - chili roasted flavor to it, and then the sauce is a little bit spicy.
I got a piece of onion in that bite as well
as - I can just taste a very - a very faint hint of shrimp paste in it. The beef dish. The cubes of beef and
Yeap, let me try to break into one of those pieces and get more. Actually, looks like it needs a little more
gravy on top of that.
All right.
Mmm, the meat is tender and
then the sauce is rich. I can, I can taste a distinct kind of almost cumin flavour.
Maybe the... Yeah, it tastes - definitely has some cumin and maybe some curry leaves. Are there curry leaves in there too?
Yeah. Okay!
Yeah.
Definitely distinct of cumin and curry leaves in there, which I love, but it doesn't have the all the
like - spicy - normal spices of a curry
but just that really strong cumin flavour. And then with a creamy coconut gravy. That's that's like. It's kind of like a beef stew.
but with cumin in it. This chicken curry...
Oh, this - that beautiful red colour.
And I've got to have that chili in this bite too.
Mmm. That was a big bite, but that is - um - that has a little bit of a sweetness to it, but I can
taste the blend of chilies in there. The onions um
The...
It has a little bit of like a lemony flavor to it, but that's just a really it's not as spicy as it looks.
But it is very, very flavorful, and has a nice chewy flavour to it. Ying and I managed to polish off that lunch.
That was quite a lot of food, but it was really good.
Um, I think my favorite was the ikan bakar. That grilled fish. And it just had a beautiful
Grilled flavor to it. I am very satisfied, and I could definitely just like sit in this chair for the rest of the afternoon.
But I think we're going to go to check into our hotel.
And we they have set us up in a hotel called the Andaman, which I think will be very nice.
Okay, we've just stopped on the side of the road to buy some snacks. Sa wat dee kap.
This is like some deep-fried corn. Deep-fried corn fritters.
You call this "chuaem kluay", which is a banana fritter. Some kind of banana fritter.
Well, that tastes like deep-fried banana bread. Oh, but it's sticky. Yeah, very good.
Okay, and then lastly. This is a doughnut she has handed us. Oh,
that is very soft and squishy and then she sprinkled some
Like Brown - is it like palm brown sugar on top. Brown sugar. Okay!
Mmm. Oh,
that is extremely like doughy and
fluffy. And then it's kind of it's kind of salty and sweet at the same time.
It has a really nice kind of almost like vanilla - maybe pandan fragrance to it. boom on top
on our top
But she is actually she speaks Thai. She's from the province, or she said she's originally from the province of Satun,
which is in the south of Thailand. It's the closest province
to Langkawi on the coast. So, it's actually. It's actually.
Langkawi is like right on the border of Thailand and Malaysia. So,
there's a lot of influence of Thai and Malaysia mixed here in Langkawi.
Okay, we just got into the hotel room. Oh!
Hello, Ying! And
before we destroy this room with taking - unpacking our bags and everything. I better give you a quick tour, the bed, and
check out all these little snacks.
They gave us - do know what we're having? It's like chips.
Some kind of chips and like dip and then there's a fresh
There's a fresh coconut here, but anyway the real highlight of this room is that view of the ocean from out here.
Just look at this view from our balcony though. Oh!
Okay, and now let's go check out the bathroom. Oh
yeah! The tub
Oh, and then look at the toilet. It looks like it's like.
It looks like it's hovering. Okay, enough of the bathroom.
Let's go sample those snacks. This looks like chips and - chips and salsa.
And then check out all this fruit they've been giving us. Oh,
about a grape.
Starting to get extremely sleepy though. I think it's about 5 p.m. now.
And it has been already a very long day since 2 a.m.. this morning.
With a few naps in the airplane, but I am starting to get drowsy though
I do want to go out and explore this hotel a bit and go to the pool and the ocean
We walked out to the beach the sun has already sort of gone down.
It's nice and Shady, but if I would have stayed in the room it definitely would have crashed pretty hard taking a nap
but I'll take a refreshing swim now.
For dinner, we are at Jala Restaurant,
which is at the Andaman Hotel, and it's a very, very nice restaurant, but you take off your shoes.
It's a sand floored restaurant.
So you take off your shoes and then they take your shoes and you can walk around barefoot.
But we got here just as the sun is going down.
So, it is
the tail end of the sunset, but it's a beautiful view and this is a really pleasant restaurant so far.
So this is the Crimson Red Snapper. Yeah, that looks...
That looks perfect. The fish has arrived for dinner, and I ordered the red snapper. A Crimson Red Snapper,
which is steamed and a couple different sauces and then a couple of different side to vegetable dishes.
But I got to go straight in for this fish.
Oh, and I'll slip that like. I'll set the skin side down.
With no sauce first.
That fish is
extremely fresh,
and just the
steaming sauce is very light. I can taste a little bit of sesame oil
maybe. And a little bit of oyster sauce a very light seasoning, but really fresh fish.
That sauce is just a tiny bit spicy. I
can taste and maybe just a tiny bit sweet as well it almost tastes like a Thai
seafood sauce. It almost has like a little zing to it. In Thailand, I have grown to using
pretty much exclusively using a spoon to eat food
So, I have almost it almost feels awkward for me to use a fork to eat
but I'm going to I'm going to do my best.
It's been a
very long day, and a tiring day,
but also a very good day and a very good introduction so far to Langkawi.
We my goal is to make a vlog every day on this trip to Langkawi. So, keep coming back
and I will be uploading them. And
thank you very much for watching this video. Hope you enjoyed it.
Please remember to give it a thumbs up and leave a comment below. And if you haven't already subscribed, make sure you
hit that subscribe button now, and I will see you on the next vlog.